الاساسي بتاع الروايه بيتكلم عن ان تجمع
ايرادات المصريين تجعل اجسادهم يفرز
اكسيرا سحريا قادرا على صنع المعجزات فانا
بتصور ان المصريين دي سرهم لما بتتجمع
ارادتهم بيصنعوا معجزه سواء في العصر من
200 سنه سواء من الف سنه سواء من 2000 سنه
سواء في العصر الحالي
ولكن حملات الهجوم ركزت على عدد من
الاخطاء التي تراوحت ما بين اختيار
الابطال وخلافات مع صاحب الموسيقى
التصويريه وملاحظات حول الديكور والملابس
وملامح بعض المجاميع من الفرنسيين
بالاضافه الى ظهور بعض الكومبارس باحذيه
حديثه خلال المعارك اكتر حاجه ضايقتني في
مسلسل سر الباتع اللي هو لما كتاسين بتاعه
اللواء لما كان الحمله الفرنسيه كان كان
شكلهم مصريين وكانوا لابسين بقى جزم عاديه
بقى وعمل في مجمل ولازم يتشاف كويس
والهنات اللي موجوده لو بفرد موجود مع ان
اللي هم قالوه معظمه مش موجود يعني ان
الفرنساويين ان اشكال الكومبارس اللي
موجود مش فرنساوي لا كلهم اجانب واحد بقى
يدخل زوم ان على واحد من الالفين كومبارس
ويطلعوا مصري ده واحد بيتصيد كل الحاجات
اللي اتعملت كلها فيها تصيد وفيها قصديه
للهجوم بعض النقاد رحبوا بسروا الباتع
وباجواء الجدل والانقسام التي تجسدها
اعمال خالد يوسف سره الباتا عامل صوره
حلوه عن الربط ما بين زمنين رجعنا لايام
احنا بنشوفها عمل كمان الفكر ما بين الفكر
الاستعماري القديم والجديد عمليه الدقه في
تناول الاحداث هناك عدم احداث التاريخيه
اولا دي توثيق انا بشوف هي دراما لا توثق
لا توثق احداث لكن انك بتقدمها للاجيال
الاجيال بتعرف من خلالها فتره الحمله
الفرنسيه او من قبل الحمله الفرنسيه لما
يكون عندك خطا ده بيعمل تشويه وتشويش عند
الاجيال الجديده
ولو حاكم
وعلى الرغم من اختلاف ار النقاد
والمتابعين يبقى للجمهور رايه النهائي في
قيمه المسلسل الذي نجح في جمع مجموعه
كبيره من الممثلين تحت قياده مخرج حقق
نجاحا ملحوظا في عالم السينما احمد عثمان
العربيه القاهره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات